[Music]
my name's Alfred Pennyworth by the way
happy WonderCon everyone they're
dropping trailers for everything this is
the teaser trailer for that Batman
prequel series based on Alfred
Pennyworth so I'll explain what's going
on with it it'll feel very familiar if
you ever watch the Peggy Carter TV show
that did a younger version of Jarvis
right after he got out of the British
SAS and started working for a young
Howard Stark
[Music]
yet
you're coming with me
[Applause]
I know I should've called first
so the difference is is this is taking
place during the 1960s so obviously it's
much later in history this is a very
young version of Thomas Wayne that you
see during the trailer there's all kinds
of stuff coming up we found out when
Swamp Thing that TV show is gonna be
dropping when Young Justice is coming
back so I'll explain all the big news
from WonderCon at the end of the video
but be sure to subscribe to get
everything if you're brand new to the
channel the Batman prequel show is gonna
be on the epics Channel it'll be 10
episodes but because it's cable it'll be
way more hardcore like you see the very
violent sexed up young version of Alfred
very different from the more modern poor
trails like Michael Caine or alfred
gough or the animated version of the
character or even Jeremy Irons version
of the character more recently come sole
master Wayne even you've got too old to
die young but most of you are probably
familiar a little bit with his back
story based on Batman the Animated
Series it is one of the few series
that's actually touched on Alfred's life
before he became a butler working for
Thomas Wayne in the Wayne family this is
meant to be that story I don't know how
many seasons is gonna wind up running
but the description just reads it
chronicles the early adventures of Bruce
Wayne's legendary Butler Alfred
Pennyworth played by Jack Bannon here by
picking up with the character in his 20s
in England when he's fresh mustn´t is a
British SAS character Alfred Pennyworth
Gotham City destiny begins to take shape
when he accepts a security job with a
young American tycoon named Thomas Wayne
played by Ben Aldridge this character
here with the moustache who is not yet
the father to Bruce Wayne so Batman has
not been born yet at this point this is
the 1960s so depending on how old you
feel like Batman is in present-day you
can guess on when Batman's gonna be born
because he's perpetually in his 20s in
most cases with the exception of Ben
Affleck's Batman who was a 40-something
Batman the teaser trailer is just meant
to give you big wide sweeping shots of
London landscape and monuments
paraphernalia to let you know where you
are this character here is Jason Fleming
he's going to be the main villain his
name is Lord Harwood but he's not a
character from the comics
presumably he's involved with Thomas
Wayne and Wayne Enterprises on some
business and maybe political level
something that threatens the UK and
America this is his personal assassin
this person is Bette Sikes who seems
like she's going to be Alfred's love
interest when he was young
most of the movies haven't really
addressed his personal relationships
before he met the Wayne family they got
into it a little bit during the Joel
Schumacher era in Batman and Robin when
they introduced the Batgirl character
and she had a prior relationship through
her family to Alfred in fact while I was
making this video I rewatched a clip of
Batman and Robin where they're talking
about a pig there's a pig during the
series like I say he's kissing this
woman that might be his love interest
Pig but the pig from Batman and Robin
was actually his sister because in the
Joel Schumacher timeline he had a sister
that sister eventually had a grandchild
named Barbara Wilson in that wound up
being this version of Batgirl my
nickname for sweet Margaret
it's good to see you again I've missed
you as I have you sleep well child you
sleep go to bed
[Music]
until they say otherwise I'm assuming
they're trying to keep the series in
continuity with the Christopher Nolan
Dark Knight trilogy usually when most
series draw references they draw on that
unless you're another one of the DC EU
movies like Shazam so you're mostly
making references to Justice League into
the other more recent films as you can
see it's meant to premiere during the
summer I think it's either gonna be June
or early July they'll be dropping a much
bigger trailer when we get closer to
Avengers endgame at the end of the month
so I'll do another video when that drops
and we'll get a better sense for what
the actual story is but just a reminder
they do have an app that you can watch
their channel on but you might have to
check a little bit depending on where
you live I don't know how it's available
outside of the United States so just do
some checking because we've had issues
with that with the DC Universe streaming
shows because right now that surface is
only in the United States so you can
have to wait for the shows that Netflix
if you live somewhere else you may
remember the classic episode of batman
the animated series called the lion in
the unicorn which basically dealt with
Alfred's life as a SAS officer so he's
called back into action by one of his
friends who needs his help the villain
of the episode was red claw who was
trying to get her hands on a doomsday
weapon left over from world war ii
called project Excalibur Alfred and his
old compatriot are the only ones that
still have the code the code winds up
being the lion in the unicorn so they
sort of have to save London in the UK
from this giant doomsday weapon so
Alfred gets to be a badass for an
episode here I thought all you dusted
was furniture a Louie Cass
what a pity
[Music]
you may also remember the time that he
flew the batwing he was a pilot during
the war so he is a decent pilot but
flying a plane is very different from
flying something like the batwing and
you [ __ ] about
[Music]
[Applause]
watch your step hi I claim this land for
Spain I think the idea with the new TV
show is that because it's cable they can
be like Netflix and just do whatever
they want it's not like Gotham on Fox
they don't have to tune the violence or
the sex or the craziness way down so
we'll get a much better look when they
drop that full trailer but speaking of
footage they've been showing off all
kinds of footage for the other DC
streaming shows that are coming later
this year they showed off footage for
swamp thing which is gonna be our first
genuine DC horror series not counting
Constantine I'm talking about legit
horror so they filmed that down in
Louisiana so we'll get a trailer for
that sometime next month but it'll
premiere after Game of Thrones ends in
May it'll be May 31st so I'll do a video
when they drop a trailer for that should
be in the next couple of weeks sometime
they also drop the first look at star
girl that series probably won't drop til
next year because it was originally
gonna come in the fall but they said the
Titan season 2 is coming in the fall but
they're rolling out Deathstroke Ravager
Jericho in Conner Kent Superboy as you
all know I've already done a couple
videos about that
[Music]
but these what the actors look like out
of costume we'll probably get a preview
of them because they just started
filming the season probably not gonna
get a trailer for that till Comic Con
later in July
like we got the Titans season 1 trailer
at Comic Con last year so same deal this
year I'll do a video for it when it
drops but if you have any special
requests just let me know in the
comments below the star girl TV show is
actually supposed to be more of a
Justice Society TV show but she's just
the lead character so that's why they're
calling it star girl better robot Stars
and Stripes from the comics behind her
if you remember they did a version of
the Justice Society and star girl on
legends of tomorrow but this looks like
a huge huge upgrade from that there will
be a trailer for Batman hush tomorrow
I'll do a video for that it should be up
in the morning while you wait for
everything click here for my non-spoiler
Eve shows a.m. review and click here for
all my other Shazam trailer videos thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]